the first Avatar film continues to hold
the record as the highest grossing movie
of all time pulling in over 2.8 billion
dollars worldwide and this more than
paid for the all-in budget for the four
planned sequels for the film coming in
at a total budget of 1 billion or 250
million per movie rumored titles for the
third to fifth installments in the
series are Avatar the seed Bearer Avatar
the Tolkien Rider and Avatar the Quest
for awat the reason that it's taken 13
years for us to finally get a sequel
lies in a series of setbacks and a
global pandemic they had to develop new
motion capture technology for the
computer Graphics the Reflections in the
water caused the mocap technology to not
track the actors faces properly so
entirely new industry altering
technology had to be developed another
issue that arose was the difficulty in
removing scuba gear from the actors
faces and bodies in the editing process
so they had to learn to hold their
breaths for long underwater scenes with
Kate Winslet breaking a record for
holding her breath in a filmmaking
performance beating out Tom Cruise and
Mission Impossible Rogue Nation at over
7 minutes long